now it's time to send in our cute little
secret weapon
i'm ready captain i love the nickname no
charles not you
i was talking about cheddar oh right
obviously
over the past month i've had him trained
to retrieve plaques and now boy
it's time to make daddy proud yes sir i
could not have been more clearly talking
to the dog
what is happening right now the last
sands are running through the hourglass
because your time is running out and you
are never going to get the plaque ah
captain stop i i just can't let you
embarrass yourself i told jake
everything he threatened to replace me
and i freaked out
hard i'm sorry it's okay i knew you
would betray me
that's why i fed you fake intel what the
plaque was never in cold cases in 1972
as if i just put it in a box unattended
uh
but you did no i didn't then how do you
explain this
i have no idea i put the plaque in my
office cheddar
come here come here come here baby hell
yeah thank you
return to my office please
[Music]
good boy cheddar bring me that karma bye
wait a minute this isn't the
championship cummerbund
this is some common cummerbund you're
not cheddar
this is some common [ __ ] okay security
system
talk to me what have i missed what's
going on
aha i'll use cheddar to steal the belt
but that's not cheddar halt and cheddar
always walk in a perfect lock step which
means someone took cheddar and that
person has the belt
but who who took cheddar
where are you coming from why do you
care i thought you weren't heisting
i'm not i'm just interested in your
comings and goings because i care about
you as a friend
okay friend i went to the bathroom well
you were gone a long time friend
you feeling okay friend no it was number
two and it was very intense
friend bless you
she sneezed dog allergies which means
that
amy took cheddar
where is my dog aren't you standing
right next to him
this [ __ ] please watch jake
jake idiot i know
one of you took cheddar and you did it
for the sake of the heist but if
anything happens to him i
will end you i couldn't bring myself to
neuter cheddar but i will
neuter you all
being pot
[Music]
cheddar cheddar shake
oh good grip pristine coat that's my
doggy
you betrayed me you'll explain yourself
later return to my office
that's a really great job what's going
on here why is cheddar here and why is
he in swim trunks because the little
sailor outfit wouldn't fit his tush
excuse me we're setting you up a twitter
account and the fastest way to get
followers is cute animal pics
i follow an account that's just this one
real grouchy chinchilla
he hates waking up so much he really
does he's like
this is ridiculous this has nothing to
do with police work exactly it's about
being noticed and right now
no one is noticing you i didn't even
realize we were talking to a third party
presently
fine if you really think it's necessary
i will establish a
social media presence but i'll be
setting up my own accounts and i assure
you
i won't be resorting to foolish gimmicks
involving my dog uh you might want to
rethink that stance because how cute
would cheddar look in this hat
please when it comes to clothes cheddar
wears little booties in the snow or
cheddar wears nothing i'm trying to get
your account reinstated but it could
take a while they say they have a lot of
nazi stuff on the front burner and when
you tweet again you should probably stop
communicating in numbers ken
there's a zero percent chance of that
besides i won't be tweeting anymore
i just got off the phone with the head
of the selection committee you did
apparently
one of the candidates for commissioner
tweeted a picture of the water main
break and
accidentally included a link to his
favorite pornographic website
uh cosplaybuttonboobs.com amateur move
you should never copy paste if you're a
perv
it's quite the scandal the candidate has
dropped out it's down to just three of
us now
so i guess this proves i was right all
along social media
it's a fool's game and only a fool would
play
and why is cheddar wearing a beret
uh kevin saw your photos and was
amused so we started an instagram
account for cheddar who now has
over 14 000 followers it's an incredible
feeling
[Music]
okay how's everybody feeling anyone else
have the weird urge to lecture
themselves
peralta what are you doing peralta what
are you doing
i conjured him captain holt
what a pleasant surprise gina told me
that you were delayed due to a wire
situation
yes the situation is you can rip them
all out but the car still works
sorry boo wait
why is the whole squad here why is
everyone wearing my clothes
my god you lost cheddar
how did you do that
sir i know you're upset but i promise
you we can find
cheddar and you can still go to paris
i'm not going to paris
now get out of my clothes get into your
clothes get out of my house
get into your cars all right we can take
it from there loud and clear
once again so sorry
oh he's so disappointed look i'm sorry
that i got you involved in this i never
should have volunteered us
no jake it's not your fault it's amy's
what
well it's not my fault blind and
jake's not the one who let cheddar go to
town in kevin sweaters please it's not
like i fed him kevin's sweaters
wait a minute guys i think this is
kevin's fault no jake it's amy's
i know you're trying to be a cool
boyfriend yet another reason why it's
not your fault but
kevin's in paris exactly and that's why
i think it's kevin's fault
i have an idea of how to find cheddar
amy don't act weird when i say this
but we're gonna need to use the binder
oh
mama oh there he is
captain holt no he can't hear me
okay well i guess we know what those
wires did i'm not in the mood for your
antics peralta
sir sir i think we know where cheddar is
will you please just get in the car
yep let me get that try now
oh i can't control the locks hang on try
now
one two three try now try now here we
come cheddar
try now here we come cheddar try now try
now try now
here we come cheddar try now cheddar
come here baby yeah
yeah oh i'm so glad to see you
how did you know he was here well
cheddar was only chewing up
kevin's stuff i figured maybe he was
acting out because he missed kevin
but the real hero here is the binder
under cheddar subsection walk subsection
walks with kevin
we found this special spot so you're
missing kevin huh
you're not the only one
i didn't cancel my trip because uh i was
worried you would burn my house down
kevin and i are having a hard time right
now
whenever we talk we fight and i'm just
afraid and just
just afraid that if i go to paris and we
fight then
sir with all due respect that's crazy
i mean you and kevin are the best couple
i know
and i'm sure whatever this is you can
get through it because
you are the strongest person i know that
was weird i said like
multiple real things consecutively yeah
felt weird but good are you proud of me
you're ruining it yep i'm just gonna
stop talking now
well i suppose i'm not gonna solve
anything by running away from it
perhaps i should go to paris what do you
think cheddar
huh oh my oh you really
are acting out i'm uh
sorry you had to see that oh you know
it's moments like these that i'm
grateful for
it's a miracle i can see not now
charles right sorry
ah perfect what what happened you know
where the bracelet is no kevin has
arrived with proof that i
am the only two-time winner of the
highest here's your comment bond raymond
i don't have time for this sir i'm gonna
go search the first floor
and i will search the second floor we
are an inseparable team
that was a devious fib i'm betraying her
even as we speak
hey again diaz and i are covertly
working together she snuck up through
the vents
this is a major reveal i feel like
you're not appreciating i don't like
these heists or what they bring out in
you oh
clement gavin clam it cheddar perhaps we
should leave no
cheddar stays he still has an important
role to play give me mr hootsworth
no one would ever think of looking
before the bracelet in cheddar's
favorite chew toy
or do you mean jake's favorite chew toy
well thank god no one was around to hear
that
[Music]
howdy i just got back from lunch with
charles who is not here i am real glad i
skipped the heist say who is winning i
don't know but i know that i am not
winning
interesting it is also not me uh why are
you guys acting so weird
weird would a person who was acting
weird laugh like this
oh carefree yes jake
oh terry you ripped yourself free yeah
maybe you should try cupping me to a
stronger medal next time yeah i don't
know the relative strength of medals
what's going on
why does terry look like an oscar
doesn't he he has the bracelet we
grabbed mr hootsworth from cheddar and
swapped it for a fake
wow terry my betrayals were all in good
fun but this really hurts
cheddar bring me mr hootsworth
it's an updated model the bow tie is
turkish blue instead of egyptian blue
how could you not have noticed this
because he's a dog and at the end of the
day
a dog is no match for jake peralta
well yours is a fake too turkish blue
bow tie come on the one time i say held
out i'm smarter than a dog
you